[Music]
and don't you have jobs news job
submitted by Oh always say don't these
[ __ ] have jobs when there's
like random traffic for no reason yeah
yeah I mean what the [ __ ] are you doing
right now on the road go get a [ __ ]
job 3 p.m. you tubers or they're not
diverse or not I'm like why why is it 3
pizzas before Wilbur though look why is
it 3 p.m. and why is there so much cars
right there night shift like salesmen
they have to go to the people you know
what it is and I'll put it to you like
this not put it to us this is how many
outsiders are in LA such as myself that
every time on the holidays is normal
traffic Thanksgiving it was so awesome
every like 90 percent in this population
all transplants did cuz all gone that
all gone during the holidays oh yeah
they went back to the Midwest or
something they said that this year was
the worst like airport traffic ever
crazy dude everything's a [ __ ] trend
everybody wants to be an actor with no
talent it's crazy parents are upset
after schools have banned them from
visiting their young children during
lunch hours what you can't visit your
kids during lunch hours no that's cool
yes why would you why would you need to
visit your kids during lunch hours yeah
like little kid oh that's nothing like
what four or five six yeah so this their
parents love them this takes place in
Connecticut and in this specific town
it's called Darien and they have a
median household income that exceeds
$200,000 so it's a very wealthy time
yeah and so the superintendent of this
district sent out a notice announcing
that they will no longer allow parents
to spend lunch with her if they miss
their kids so much why even put him in
school because it's a lock
there's home school Oh church at you
they probably don't put their kids in
the home school because you say home
school Scoob yeah there are parents that
were crying
Wow there were that upset you have
separation anxiety yeah the most because
they're like it feels like I just got
punched in the gut oh my god the parents
they're tied to the umbilical cord yeah
what do you guys want to be your kids do
we do we want to whet visit your kids no
I like so I throught like I really enjoy
independence and I really enjoy when
people are independent so I want my
child to be equipped with independence
and beasts offices I've never visited my
son during lunch oh that's dope if if I
have a kid and in high school my kid
comes up to me and he goes dad I love
you I'm gonna beat him the [ __ ] up so
you're embarrassing yourself you go
inside you [ __ ] ignore me all right
no I don't want ain't nobody Malik's if
I come here son I love you yep that's
embarrassing like I used to get
embarrassed like like when my mom picked
me up I'd be like oh you know okay kids
at a certain age don't want you to see
their kids you know I told my dad like
three blocks down yeah me too
this kindergarten I never had that belt
like what my pit my dad ever picked me
up from school this shows go by after
walk home I was happy I'd rather walk
home dude I hate it
no cuz I had to walk home seven days of
uh five or no three days out of the week
the other two days because my those are
the assigned days my dad could come see
me when her parents divorced oh [ __ ] I
watch Mike I just walk home those two
days two is all the cool kids walk home
with their backpacks below their ass and
they walk like two miles that way you
know worked and lived in the next city
over so it took me forever to get along
with a lot it was like a 30-minute an
hour walk oh she's pretty
yeah yeah dad I hated school since the
moment I went to preschool I never liked
it it was so boring and in every time
that time came I was like this is so
boring I was like everything sucks you
don't like playing with the drive-up
starfish I mean okay arts and crafts and
like Jolie I like PE if you like Toby
times where I knew I liked it but for
the most
part it was like really stressful to go
there to like do it yeah it was it was
really painful I like summer camps
though so it could be like the
curriculum just didn't I couldn't I
couldn't deal with the way the teaching
style was or whatever but it felt like a
struggle for me since day one
and summer camps there's any summer
thing it always just felt more relaxed
like it was just it was fun yeah it was
shorter I mean you're still learning but
yeah it just felt like you're swimming
and there's other activities yeah I feel
you man you have you know I feel that I
felt like it just like imprison like
just like I remember did you say in
prison yeah just like you're just
captive there person first three classes
you feel like you don't even want to
look at the clock because you're like
God and then it's just like you just you
just like waiting for that last class I
think it's also part of life though you
know a lot in life a lot of times it's
boring and you just can't do what you
want to do like you forgot the DMV it's
like [ __ ] it there's no other way around
it so it kind of prepares you for a real
life - do you ever feel like liberating
like taking the Hall Pass
unless you're just free for I always
pretended to go to the bathroom yeah
just so I could get up and get air and
stuff yeah yeah so you what are your
reasons why so why aren't you why don't
you why didn't you guys want to visit
your kids or why won't you visit your
kids in the future just for independence
so there it for me so right now like in
the baby stages like when I'm at home
and I'm playing with tyka if he comes
and interacts with me I'm fully
committed while play or do whatever but
like let's say we're just playing his
little playpen and he goes off right and
he's like playing with like something
and I could see he's like in the zone by
studying [ __ ] that I try not to
interfere cuz that's how I am like when
I get into stuff I can see when someone
likes light you know like really dive
deep and I could see his little gears
work you know what the furthest square
looks different than other squares yes I
could see little things like going in
there so like I like that so if I had a
kid and he's at school I don't know what
he's doing by those little gears are
turning so I don't even want to
interrupt when he's in the zone
maybe like the social thing to like I
don't want him to always be attached to
me to a point where it's like I can be
anywhere without my mommy like and then
it's only making it worse cuz then no
matter what then I come to the point
where I can't do man I've we have a
friend her kid is so hyper dependent on
honor is so crazy like I've never seen a
child like so cleaning towards a parent
before in my life you know mom I have a
hand on a parent at all times or they
break down physical contact physical
contact for that kid well yeah but it's
also cuz the parent to also they like it
they like it yeah I mean bill I think
it's so cute oh I got a poor [ __ ] like
dude your kids a little [ __ ]
yeah I think security security blankets
are stunning growth but then my personal
experience was a dreadful [ __ ] boring
mentally not even stimulating experience
it was torture and I think if I I mean
the separation anxiety that's what kids
have to just get over and same with the
parents right it's hard it might be hard
for both but then I'm hoping that
schools now have changed the way that
they teach or teach you know and in
making things a little bit different for
children because the way that it I just
remember sitting in there like I already
know this this is [ __ ] boring likely
let me go like that yeah even at the big
my god you know what we were doing in
kindergarten is we were [ __ ]
following lines like this and I was like
this is so [ __ ] dumb like let me
learn the alphabet or something if you
remember that's pretty normal because
you you don't have what does that called
dicksterity yeah so they're teaching you
how that they're prepping you to start
writing I get it I just think I was like
I got a it's frustrating you know like
because you repeatedly do it and once
you get it you have to do it again oh
and again and let's move on everybody
has to get it yeah so I'm just like yeah
I just want to go out and play please
yeah yeah I don't know maybe cuz I was
hyperactive to I was like I got my work
done I want to play I want to play but
it was hard it was difficult dude yes it
really
as parents here in Darien they are just
so upset about this decision from
superintendent because they were like
they're like yeah you know like we want
to be there for a kid because some
schools I felt they'll allow children or
parents to come in for children's
birthdays or other special occasions but
for this specific town it seems like
before their [ __ ] birthday don't show
up to the [ __ ] school man celebrate
they [ __ ] at home [ __ ] is wrong with you
man but you can't be independent and
have their own [ __ ] life
yeah you guys ever have classmates where
their parents would bring to McDonald's
during the effort this one would have
[ __ ] the demon friend yeah this one
would have a subway chick-fil-a
McDonald's I'm like [ __ ] Bradford
dude every time that happened I'll be
like can I have like you despise that
kid mr. Canales is class so you wanted
to like take his Big Mac from them no I
just wish I just wish my parents bought
the same thing I don't think anybody you
know I just ever had a pair of not a
bully no I guess I just rate mentality
no I do that every time every time a kid
in my limit reach school had like some
kind of McDonald's or whatever right a
bunch of vulture ass elementary school
kids would surround them be like can I
get a french fry the shot can I get one
too sharp
please and then he will give like one to
each person oh yeah like that one Friday
yeah that's that's got a nice gesture
yeah but you will see like a big [ __ ]
huddle around the McDonald's and like
you guys remember that stuff look at my
kid all that weird stinky food that he's
made fun of for kimchi fried rice all
the other stuff we had this one class
named classmate kid dude I had the
kimchi fried rice nice bomb did you like
you as a kid I liked it but my bike dad
made me feel weird about it why don't
you have a sandwich
[Laughter]
kimchi fried rice I've always been like
a weird off kid and I didn't I think
since I was a young kid I didn't really
care about like I did to a certain
extent but not as much as other kids
right so if I wanted kimchi fried rice
at lunch [ __ ] take him I'll go [ __ ]
what you think of what it smells like I
wanted to eat it but then my dad was
like no dude the kids are gonna think
it's weird and I told my dad like I
don't care I want to eat this what if
like he was hearing that from other
parents he's like oh I'm gonna I'm not
gonna let David go through this so then
he does that but it's not you know what
you wanted I think he just wanted to
like protect me and stuff but I'm like I
want to eat the [ __ ] kimchi fried
rice I don't give a [ __ ] what these kids
think dude
I just want to eat that [ __ ] but my dad
didn't did you guys ever usually trade
lunches
oh yeah Twix my mom always want the
[ __ ] white bread sandwiches in the
ham and the mail and the cheese the
basic ass under that basic [ __ ] you
cheese basic ham yes and [ __ ] iron
kid's bread dude yeah that [ __ ] was
delicious
I like Wonder Bread I still love Wonder
Bread dude all day yeah dude I I made
the stuffing this year with the Wonder
Bread move so [ __ ] good dude it's so
dope you get about in elementary school
now it was great memories yeah memories
[ __ ] what's it called that I call it
the refugee bread that [ __ ] Wonder
Bread smells weird - that's like alcohol
smell doing that on the wine oh yeah
gonna get stuck on the roof of the
cafeteria - you know it smelt a certain
way yeah I love that
yeah it's honest all of those sandwiches
I will smush him a little too because
they would get like nice it'll stick on
in your mouth like you said on yeah I
got I got I got made fun of for having
like little prep Japanese stuff and
whatever and it's be proud yeah but I
mean like I'll just like it's hard on
your kid
there we go what is that yeah yeah and
then I'll be like I'll change you and
then they were curious so they're like
okay yeah they actually tricky they were
like yeah and then they still traded me
and ate it
yeah it's like that's $18 butter jelly
sandwich mushes
[Music]
[Music]